le thème de la soirée le thème de la
présentation c'est jugaad ou innovation
frugal comment faire plus avec moins
alors là je vous montre des frigos donc
rassurez vous je vais pas vendre des
frigos à des pingouins
mais par contre je vais essayer d'en
vendre à des indiens états africains
donc j'essaye de vendre un frigo mois
occidental à des indiens et des
africains
qu'est ce que j'aime poser comme
question je vais me dire en inde et en
afrique
il fait chaud donc est ce que je vais
faire banalement je vais augmenter la
puissance de mon frigo pour pouvoir
répondre à leurs besoins
les illustrations je vous montre en fait
c'est des illustrations que vous
trouverez dans la dans l'esprit dans la
philosophie jugaad donc la première
illustration c'est la réponse qui a été
donnée par des indiens ses frigos
mythique houle qui est un des éléments
fondateurs de l'innovation frugal donc
c'est un potier indien qui a inventé un
frigo à destination du public local gros
intérêts il n'a pas besoin d'électricité
et ya une seconde solution que
j'apprécie beaucoup aussi
c'est la solution qu'a été inventé par
les touareg qui elle aussi est très
maligne qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
je vais pas vous exposer qu'un poids
règle forcément dans le désert il aura
des difficultés en électricité donc est
ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont en fait
utilisé deux jarres ils en ont misé une
dans la seconde et j'utilise une
propriété qui est toute simple c'est
qu'en mai de l'eau au soleil s évaporent
et en s'évaporant sa température baisse
donc ça suffit à réfrigérer l'intérieur
de l'enceinte et ça permet en fait à
l'utilisateur de conserver ses produits
arrêt dans la littérature on dit
qu'effectivement ils peuvent conserver
ou de conserver une tomate ils vont la
conserver 20 jours donc ça répond à
leurs besoins
et là maintenant je vais essayer de vous
faire partager une tranche de vie c'est
à dire ce que j'ai vécu moi alors là on
va changer de registre
le poids des mots le choc des photos
rassurez vous ça je n'ai pas vécu j'ai
pris un incident
sur le site du ministère un vieil
accident la photo correspond pas
l'accident d'ailleurs mais c'est pour
vous montrer ce que ça peut représenter
un accident de ce type là donc qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé en fait sur un site de
stockage de gaz
à un moment il ya eu un
dysfonctionnement quelque part et il ya
du gaz qui a circulé dans le tuyau dans
le mauvais sens
un classique le problème c'est qu'en
fait il est remonté dans une chaudière
ça fait exploser la chaudière et selon
le site du ministère les pompiers ont
mis aux alentours de 45 minutes pour
être un centre
donc ça ce sont des accidents graves
touchent du bois j'en ai jamais vécu
mais moi en tant qu'ingénieur en
maintenance dans une entreprise dans
différentes entreprises
j'ai fait la pharma j'ai fait la
pétrochimie
j'ai fait de la métallurgie j'ai vu quoi
j'ai vu des petits accidents et autant
comme celui-ci ce gros accident on le
traite parce qu'effectivement il aux
incidents on va mettre en place de la
technologie dont qu'est ce qui s'est
passé on va mettre en place un capteur
on va mettre en place de l'intelligence
pour essayer d'empêcher tout simplement
un fluide de circuler dans l'autre sens
ça c'est la vision qu'on va dire commune
courante gros risques grosse solutions
techniques mais imaginez un cas plus
simple geipan d'illustration j'ai une
entreprise d'agroalimentaire
ils vont mélanger de la confiture de
fraises avec la confiture de coings
mais en fait il voulait faire des
biscuits à la fraise à moi
personnellement j'aime pas la confiture
de coings je vais pas les manger des
biscuits mais c'est un cas plus simple
sur une anomalie comme ça elle va être
traité à la va comme je te pousse
pourquoi parce qu'ils abattent
dangereuses derrière on a perdu un peu
de confiture mais moi je me suis dit à
travers la mise en oeuvre de solutions
simples et la question je me suis posée
elle est aussi bête que ça c'est à dire
j'ai un fluide que je vais empêcher de
circuler dans le mauvais sens et je veux
trouver une solution simple je me suis
mis une contrainte comme les indiens et
les africains a précédemment je me suis
dit je vais laisser mettre en oeuvre une
solution qui n'utilisent pas
d'électricité
ça c'est l'idée je vais pas vous faire
un cours de mécanique des fluides
ça aurait pas grand intérêt par contre
qu'est ce qu'elle illustre cette idée qu
en fait j'ai mis en oeuvre des solutions
mécaniques simples qui étaient à la
disposition de tout le monde depuis bien
longtemps
et je les ai des formes et agencer
autrement qu'est ce que j'ai fait en
fait j'ai mis un plat plaît donc un club
et c'est un dispositif mécanique tout
simple qui empêche un fluide d'aller
dans le mauvais sens mais là je n'ai pas
utilisé pour assurer cette fonction là
j'ai utilisé comme capteur ça c'est la
première russe du système la seconde
ruse c'est que j'ai utilisé un défaut
alors là je vais pas aller dans le
détail de la mécanique des fluides et
j'ai cherché à amplifier le défaut de ce
club
ce clapet à travers une membrane et je
vous expliquera à brac osr est ensuite
pour assurer de manière sur l'isolation
cercle produit je puisse l'arrêter j'ai
mis une vanne ou un robinet mais
rappelez vous je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure je m'étais donc imposé comme
contrainte de ne pas avoir d'électricité
à disposition donc une vanne je vais pas
vous faire un cours
elle va pas se fermer tout seul donc
soit j'ai quelqu'un qui va surveiller ce
qui se passe dans ce trio qui va fermer
la vanne c'est pas la solution que j'ai
prise soit je vais mettre à disposition
d'énergie et willy thaler d'énergie j'en
ai pas comment j'ai refusé je me suis
dit l'énergie j'en ai pas mais par
contre ce que je vais essayer de faire
c'est de la stocker
je les stocke dans un ressort voilà tout
simplement est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure sur l'astuce de la
membrane c'est qu'en fait le défaut du
clapage et amplifier et bien ça permet
juste à vous imaginez un petit crochet
qui va venir se libérer et qui va venir
permettra la vente de se fermer la
boucle est bouclée
j'ai une solution qui est simple qu'est
ce qui se cache derrière cette solution
simple des applications multiples et
c'est ça l'intérêt de la pensée jugaad
c'est à dire qu'à travers la mise en
oeuvre de solutions simples on ouvre un
champ d'investigation et d'applications
qui est extrêmement large
en plus d'autres intéresse c'est qu'on
est tellement noyé par la technologie
parfois qu'on comprend plus à quoi ça
sert là je vous ai fait un cours de
mécanique des fluides en deux minutes
je pense que vous avez tout à fait saisi
à quoi ça servait ce dire que demain si
dans votre environnement dans votre
univers industriel ou ailleurs il y
avait un événement qui se produisait
vous diriez maintien et une solution
toute simple qui existe je vais la
mettre en oeuvre
ensuite dans la démarche ça a été ma
démarche
j'ai une idée c'est magnifique c'est
formidable mais enthousiaste mais il ya
quand même un verdict c'est quelque part
on va déposer un brevet un brevet c'est
extraordinaire parce qu'on fait une
recherche d'antériorité la recherche
d'antériorité c'est la base de données
du génie humain
il ya beaucoup d'idées extraordinaire et
qu'est ce que j'ai trouvé dans cette
base de données une invention un brevet
qui date de 1956 globalement l'inventeur
a eu le même problème comment sr qui
voulait empêcher un fluide d'aller dans
le mauvais sens il a utilisés
globalement la même ruse cirque il a bon
an mal an utiliser un clapet pour venir
mesurer le sens du fluide mais par
contre il a été moins jugaad que moi et
pourtant en 1956 l'électricité était un
peu moins disponibles qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
il s'est dit je vais utiliser de
l'électricité pour fermer ma vanne vous
avez brevet de 56 vous avez un problème
2016 le brevet 2016 c'est quoi c'est un
simple croquis je vous montre ce
coquille après on me dirait non non non
c'est pas possible c'est trop simple
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit fréquemment il
m'a dit c'est pas possible que tu es
plus inventé ça en 2016 ça déjà dû être
inventé avant l'antériorité a prouvé que
non et ensuite c'est trop simple ça
pourra pas fonctionner donc on passe à
l'étape d'après le prototype assez un
peu plus joli quand même j'ai trois
décès à wow etc
donc on a travaillé avec une équipe
d'étudiants en essayant de conserver la
pensée je gâte c'est à dire se dire on
reste sur un dispositif qui doit être
généralisée
on doit se concentrer sur la solution
démontrer à des gens que ça fonctionne
les étudiants il avait six mois devant
eux pour faire un truc qui marche
ils ont fait un truc qui fonctionnait et
derrière depuis que la vidéo et publiée
en fait les gens je leur dis d'art
garder sa marge
voilà la preuve et donc j'ai pas pu
m'empêcher de citer bertrand piccard qui
est quelqu'un que j'admire énormément et
qui résume effectivement le doute et le
travail que doit faire un pionnier pour
réussir à prouver aux gens que ça
fonctionne les pionniers au début on les
croit fou on se moque de leur échec
effectivement quand j'ai pondu ce
croquis au début on a pris un peu pour
un cinglé et puis à la fin quand ça
fonctionne les gens lui disent mais
c'est absolument évident j'ai un profond
respect pour cette personne et j'ai pas
pu m'empêcher de mettre une citation de
sabah le futur alors là ce stade qu'il
ait montré tout à l'heure et on m'a dit
mais c'est bizarre parce que ton futur
il va dans le mauvais sens en fait
visuellement le futur on le fait à l'est
par là bas c'est peut-être inconscient
mais en fait ma vision du futur c'est
qu'effectivement on doit aussi
s'inspirer du passé et c'était aussi ma
manière d'appréhender les choses c'est à
dire que c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure j'ai une fâcheuse tendance à
sortir du cadre
et peut-être que quand tout le monde dit
le futur il est par là moi je pense
qu'il est de notre côté mais globalement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya trois
ans j'ai eu l'idée
je me suis dit je vais y aller j'ai créé
une start up de mécanique effectivement
parle beaucoup de startups en règle
générale de start up de technologies
d'internet de choses de ce type là et
moi j'ai créé une start up de mécanique
suite à ça qu'est ce qui s'est passé
j'ai rencontré des gens j'étais
accompagné il ya des gens qui ont cru et
vraiment ça m'a fait chaud au coeur
d'être accompagné et les gens qui m'ont
pris pour un fou mais je retiens que les
gens qui m'ont aidé et qui m'ont
accompagné je les remercie et depuis
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à partir du
moment où on a créé un démonstrateur
on a montré aux gens que ça fonctionnait
qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis six
mois environ j'ai signé un partenariat
avec un fonds souverain qui va m'aider à
promouvoir l'idée est actuellement je
suis en contact avec des multinationales
dans le domaine de la robinetterie et
des fluides pour promouvoir cette idée
donc c'est une aventure je m'étais pas
dit que c'était impossible je m'étais
dit que c'était possible mais je pensais
que ce serait autrement beaucoup plus
modestement et en fait cette aventure
elle est en train de prendre un essor
qui qui est extraordinaire
et pour conclure si j'avais quelques
idées à retenir c'est face à une
problématique
n'hésitez pas sortir du cadre parce que
quand on sort du cadre
parfois on est amené à proposer des
solutions qui sont redoutablement simple
et caen propose une solution simple
qu'est ce que ça implique c'est simple
c'est facile à comprendre
c'est fiable ça coûte pas cher et donc
ça peut être généralisée ça c'est une
des notions importantes et la
philosophie jugaad nous impose nous
guide vers des solutions simples donc
c'est une philosophie qui a de la traite
est par ailleurs à travers effectivement
la mise en oeuvre de solutions simples
c'est pas que l'innovation technologique
qu'il faut voir il faut aussi voir que
ça nous projette dans le monde de demain
si demain ce dispositif qui permet de
préserver l'environnement et de
préserver également les ressources
il ya quelque part on aura gagné et on
aura fait avancer et on aura inspiré le
probant je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]